الى الوضع في مناطق شمال سوريا الان التي
تعيش حاله من القلق والترقب خشيه من تدخل
بري للقوات التركيه مع تواصل التهديدات من
انقره وعلى الرغم من التحذيرات الدوليه من
اي عمليه عسكريه تركيه بريه في الشمال
السوري اعادت انقره اليوم التاكيد على
انها ماضيه في تحركاتها العسكريه المتحدث
باسم الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم كالين اكد
ان التوغل برا قد يبدا في اي لحظه وان
العمليات العسكريه ستستمر على ان تحدد
انقره زمانها ومكانها ومنذ ايام اطلقت
انقره سلسله من الضربات الجويه والقصف
المدفعي المتواصل ضد مواقع لحزب العمال
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب في شمال
العراق وسوريا بعدما اتهمتها بالمسؤوليه
عن تفجير اسطنبول في الثالث عشر من الشهر
الجاري كما شلنت القوه التركيه خلال
السنوات الماضيه ثلاث عمليات عسكريه في
شمال سوريا حينها ارسلت ودعمت وشكلت فصائل
سوريه مسلحه موليه لها في
والى الجنوب من الحدود التركيه طلبت قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه من روسيا التدخل لمنع
هجوم تركي بري بري ضد مناطقها وفق ما قال
قائدها العام مظلوم
طلب من قائد القوات الروسيه في سوريا
ضروره ايقاف الهجمات تركيه خاصه مع تزايد
التهديدات واسرار تركيا علشان عمليه
البريه فيما يتعلق بالولايات المتحده قال
مظلوم عبدي انه مازال يخشى هجوما بريا
تركيا على الرغم من التاثيرات الامريكيه
وطلب واشنطن برساله اقوى مع الحديث عن
تعزيزات تركيا غير مسبوقه على الحدود عبد
دعى الولايات المتحده الى التلويح بشيء
ملموس اكثر لكبح جماح تركيا بعدما قال انه
تلقى تاكيدات واضحه من كل من واشنطن ومسكو
بانهما تعارضان اي دخول تركي برا عبر
الحدود لكن رد واشنطن جاء محبطا بعد ان
اكد البنتاجون قبل نحو الساعه بانه قلص
الدوريات المشتركه شمال سوريا بسبب
العمليات العسكريه التركيه لم يفوت عبدي
تحذير انقره من انه في حال نفذت تركيا
تهديداتها فهذا سيعني توسيع دائره الحرب
لتشمل كامل الحدود السوريه مع تركيا فيما
وصفها عبدي بمعركه وجود حتى الان ومنذ ان
اطلقت انقره ضربتها الجويه في العشرين من
الشهر الجاري قتل 75 شخصا بينهم 10 مدنيين
بينما كانت الغالبيه من مقاتلي قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه والتشكيلات التابعه لها وقوه
النظام وفق المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
[موسيقى]